I'm dr. Larry alt steal I am head of
neuroscience clinical research in the
neuroscience research units at Pfizer
grot research laboratories in Groton
Connecticut we've talked a lot of today
about genes involved in Alzheimer's
disease apoe a PP ps1 and ps2 recently
other genes have been discovered to be
associated with Alzheimer's disease can
you tell us what this has taught us
about the pathology of AD and what it
might mean for treatment in addition to
a PP priests and Owen 1854 there are a
number of genes that have been
associated with increasing the risk for
Alzheimer's disease they seem however to
be effects that you can only detect when
you look at an enormous population and
so far we can't reduce those two like
mutations that we can test for an
individual person so for a PP and ps1
and ps2 and a pony for we know exactly
where to look in the gene to see where
the mistakes might be that cause
Alzheimer's disease or jeans like sorrel
one which is one of the chains or
clustering we don't know exactly where
to look we can't we can't we don't have
the precision to know where to do how to
do a test that will reduce that to an
individual risk we can only look at that
at the population love you what also
these studies may tell us is that our
Sammy disease is not cautious by a
single affect their big many you know
many factors many gene of their melodies
that you know in concert contribute to
the development of the disease and it's
not going to be just a single you know a
single gene it doesn't have to be it you
know I mean jeans could be important but
it doesn't have to be a genius no miles
it's not all about genes it's there is
this part of science which is called AP
genetic which means it's not in gene the
change of the combination of genes but
could be factors that I external to the
gene that effect in a different way
the jeans are idiots we need to keep our
mind open broad medallion or what do we
do on this thing without focusing access
it is important let's not be on I think
the question really prompts a broader
question and that is as genomic
technology gets more and more powerful
and we can identify genes that have tiny
effects for this disease or that disease
and we need large large populations of
people to see these tiny effects what do
we do with that information is that is
that actionable and I think we we still
don't know none of us know where this is
heading and how we're going to harness
this genomics technology in terms of
what these rare genes or more Jesus
we've discovered in populations have
told us about the pathology for everyone
that's been tested they seem to dovetail
into we call the amyloid hypothesis all
of these genes whatever you turn them
down in a mouse model they make the
amyloid buildup worse so they all have
so far reinforced the the amyloid model
of how the disease begins we don't know
exactly how that's how that relates to
all forms of common disease but these
genetic risk factors whatever we've
identified them all seemed if it's
possible to fit them into the a unifying
picture of the pathology